[Musik]
wusstet ihr dass frankreich das land mit
der größten ausschließlichen
wirtschaftszone der welt ist
ausschließliche wirtschaftszone sind
jene teile des meeres in denen ein
einziger staat die alleine im
wirtschaftlichen rechte besitzt für
frankreich seht ihr diese auf der
folgenden karte
[Musik]
was er gerade gesehen haben sind nicht
weniger als 11,7 millionen
quadratkilometer meer in denen
frankreich das alleinige recht besitzt
zu fischen und den meeresgrund
auszubeuten das ist in etwa die 18 fache
fläche des französischen mutter landes
beziehungsweise ungefähr die fläche der
usa wobei natürlich mehr als 96 prozent
dieser gewässer nicht an das mutterland
sondern an die französischen
überseegebiete grenzen überrascht wenn
ich denke es ist kein geheimnis dass
frankreich eine lange koloniale
vergangenheit hat eine vergangenheit
dann der ist immer noch gebiete auf der
ganzen welt kontrolliert
[Musik]
amerika afrika ozeanien und sogar ein
riesiges gebiet für die erforschung der
antarktis mit ausnahme von asien haben
die franzosen damit die hoheit über
gebiete auf allen kontinenten der erde
und da jedes küstengebiet anspruch auf
eine 200 seemeilen breite
ausschließliche wirtschaftszone hat
ergibt sich das was wir gerade gesehen
haben
[Musik]
aber vergessen wir nicht dass diese
überseeischen gebiete aus wie in anderen
drücken strategisch wichtig sind sie
ermöglichen es frankreich überall auf
der welt militärisch aktiv zu sein und
seinen geo politischen einfluss zu
stärken
sie machen frankreich zum beispiel so
einzigen europäischen macht die gebiete
im indopazifik besitzt die
überseegebiete sind der schlüssel dazu
dass frankreich nach den usa und
russland das land mit der drittgrößten
militärischen präsenz in der welt ist
ein weiteres beispiel ist kourou in
französisch-guyana wo sich der
weltraumbahnhof der esa befindet
[Musik]
aber wie steht es eigentlich um diese
über sie besitzen frankreichs in die
walzen diese gebiet auch wirklich ein
teil der kommission haben sie einen
ähnlichen lebensstandard sind die
menschen dort glücklich darüber teil des
französischen republik zu sein und wie
werden sie von paris behandelt nun in
diesem video und werden wir versuchen
diesen stil unbekannte seite frankreichs
etwas besser kennen zu lernen und wir
werden uns dafür auf eine weiterreise in
einige seiner wichtigsten und
interessantesten überseegebiete begeben
also schnallt euch an verlegen gleich ab
liberté egalité fraternité
das ist der berühmte wahlspruch der
französischen republik ob er aber auch
für ihre überseegebiete und die etwa
drei millionen dort lebenden franzosen
gilt kann angezweifelt werden das gilt
zumindest für die egalité die gleichheit
und damit eigentlich auch für die
fraternité die brüderlichkeit viele der
weit vermutet entstammt liegenden
franzosen sind unzufrieden mit ihrer
situation und an gründen dafür mangelt
es nicht lasst uns zuerst einen blick in
den geldbeutel wersen der erste grund
für die unzufriedenheit in den
überseegebieten sind ihre relativ
schlechten sozio-ökonomischen umständen
[Musik]
in den französischen übersee debatte
muss sind die armutsquoten viel höher
als in den französischen
ballungsgebieten wären zum beispiel im
europäischen frankreich der anteil der
bevölkerung unterhalb der armutsgrenze
weiter 15 prozent liegt ist in anderen
gebieten der publik deutlich höher so
liegt die armutsquote in new york bei
sage und schreibe 77 prozent in
französisch-guyana bei 53 in guadeloupe
bei 34,5 und martinique immerhin noch
bei 30 prozent
[Musik]
okay aber die armutsquoten sind relativ
und werden besonders in frankreich durch
das übergewicht der dichtbesiedelten air
france patient lasst uns also lieber
einen blick auf das bip pro kopf werfen
ist auch hier unterschiede nun ändert
das recht der französische weise gebiet
ist die insel la reunion dort wird ein
pro kopf bip von etwa 24.000 euro
erwirtschaftet während das erste
departement des französischen mutterland
ist ronaldo war ein pro kopf bip von
etwa 30.000 200 euro vorzuweisen hat das
sind 26 prozent mehr hinzu kommt dass
diese orte in hohem maße von geldern aus
den französischen staatshaushalt und
neuerdings auch und mitteln der
europäischen union abhängig sind
[Musik]
die schuldigen führt diese situation
sind jedoch nicht nur vor ort sondern
auch in paris zu suchen denn sie hat
viel mit mangelnder wirtschaftlicher
freiheit und zentralisierung zu tun im
gegensatz zu london dass ein
überseegebieten seit jeher große
freiheit gewährt hat paris einen ganz
anderen weg eingeschlagen so gilt der
großtat aller gesetze einschließt nicht
der steuergesetzgebung und der handels
vorschriften allen überseegebieten
gleichermaßen egal wie verschieden sie
sind er ist handelt sich hier wieder
einmal um einen besonderen ausdruck des
typisch französischen interventionismus
zwar wurden im jahr 2000 einige
dezentralisierung maßnahmen durchgeführt
sodass in den überseegebieten inzwischen
zum teil verschiedene regeln und gesetze
gelten sie bieten insbesondere einige
steuerliche anreize in einigen fällen
wie zb in neukaledonien werden sogar
eigene gesetzgebenden organe
eingerichtet aber das war nicht
annähernd genug denn weiterhin läuft das
meiste über paris und diese unrühmliche
tradition reicht schon lange zurück
tatsächlich sind diese gebiete auch nur
in geringem maße in den internationalen
handel eingebunden
[Musik]
das ist eine folge des französischen
kolonialpolitik die darauf zielte
handelsbeziehungen bevorzugt zwischen
den kolonien und den mutterland
einzurichten so wurden vor allem agrar
vorprodukte ernst mutterland geliefert
während die kolonien gute absatzmärkte
für dessen fertigprodukte waren die
schaffung einer wirtschaft die einen
hohen mehrwert erzeugen kann so oder so
gezielt verhindert zudem ist die
wirtschaftliche rückständigkeit diverse
gebiete auf den einstmals massiven
einsatz von sklavenarbeit zurückzuführen
man konzentrierte sich auch hierzu auf
gewerbe mit geringer wertschöpfung wie
die produktion von zuckerrohr bananen
baumwolle oder kakao aber die
wirtschaftliche kluft ist nicht die
einzige kluft zwischen dem mutterland
und den überseegebieten es gibt da auch
erhebliche politische und soziale
unterschiede die in einigen fällen sogar
zu unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen führen
[Musik]
neukaledonien ohne abhängigkeiten wägt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
neukaledonien liegt in einem appell des
südpazifik es besticht vor allem durch
seine spektakuläre flora und fauna sowie
durch seine erheblichen nickelvorkommen
zusammen mit französisch polynesien ist
es dass überseegebiet mit der größten
autonomie zugleich sind es die einzigen
französischen gebiete die von der un als
hoheitsgebiete ohne selbst regierung
ausgeführt werden das heißt die un
erwartet hier eine die kolonialisierung
der fall neukaledoniens ist aber ein
ganz besonderer bereits im jahr 1998
wurde das abkommen von nunmehr
geschlossen mit welchen bestimmte
befugnisse von der französischen
regierung auf dieses abgelegene gebiet
übertragen worden und es wurde vor allem
auch vereinbart dass bis zu drei
unabhängigkeits referendum abgehalten
werden können dies geschah dann in den
jahren 2018 2020 und 2021 bei allen
stimmte die mehrheit für den verbleib in
frankreich warum ist der fall neu
kaledonien es dann aber etwas besonderes
nun was die volksabstimmungen angeht
gibt es etwas zu beachten ein großer
teil der neu kaledonien die für die
unabhängigkeit sind nahm nämlich gar
nicht an ihnen teil die separatisten
waren der auffassung dass der
abstimmungstermin aufgrund der pandemie
unfair gelegt sei daher wollten sie
durch einen boykott der abstimmung und
durch die folglich niedrige
wahlbeteiligung das letzte mögliche
referendum delegitimieren
unabhängigkeit befürworter in
neukaledonien leben legitimität des nein
votums ab und so gewann beim letzten
referendum 2020 dass nun alle davon dass
max 96 5 der stimmen die wahlbeteiligung
aber lag nun bei 44 prozent man kann
also davon ausgehen dass ich hätte der
bevölkerung nicht für den verbleib in
frankreich ist es handelte sich dabei
überwiegend um die nachfahren der kanak
der ursprünglichen bewohner
neukaledoniens und diese unzufriedenheit
hat viele gründe wichtig werden dabei
die erinnerungen an den bürgerkrieg der
80er jahre sein und auch dass die
canucks sich als marginalisiert
empfinden auch die verteilung der
gewinne aus dem nickel abbau und die
daraus resultierenden umweltschäden sind
ein schwieriges thema insgesamt fühlen
sich viele benachteiligt und gegenüber
der pariser regierung
machtlos
der erste teil frankreichs
aber neukaledonien ist nicht das einzige
französische überseegebiet dass sich in
gewisser weise von paris an den rand
gedrängt fühlt betrachten wie etwa den
fall von mayotte einer französischen
insel zwischen madagaskar und mosambik
mit einer fläche etwa halb so groß wie
hamburg es handelt sich um das bei
weitem ernsteste französische übersee
département mayotte war die einzige der
vier komoren inseln die 1974 dafür
stimmte teil frankreichs zu bleiben die
übrigen drei inseln bildeten einen
unabhängigen staat ist übrigens auch
nicht gut ergangen ist
und obwohl major zu frankreich gehört
und mit einer spektakulären landschaft
ein beliebtes reiseziel ist liegt ein
großer teil der bevölkerung in ärmlichen
unterkünften wie in der dritten welt und
viele straßen sind nicht einmal passiert
trotzdem ist die situation auf meyer
deutlich besser als auf dem rest der
komoren so kommen besonders von dort
viele einwanderer der wunsch frankreichs
und damit der europäischen union zu sein
hat viele koreaner nach mayotte gelockt
so sind heute noch 45 prozent der
materna auf der insel selbst geboren und
70 prozent der hauptstadt maputo
geborenen kinder stammen von
ausländischen müttern
so den wirtschaftlichen problemen und
dem chancen mangel kommen soziale
probleme aller art darunter auch die
immer weiter schrumpfen die sicherheit
und das erklärte nachrichten wie diese
mayotte ohne holen französische
inselbewohner treiben fremde zu sammeln
eine gruppe von einwohnern der
französischen insel mayotte im indischen
ozean hat mutmaßlich illegal in den
ganzen zusammengetrieben und zur
örtlichen polizei gebracht all das
schlägt sich natürlich auch politisch in
schlagzeilen wie dieser nieder
marine le pen in mayotte in führung
durchbruch für jean luc mélenchon
protestwahl gegen emanuele makro tja so
sieht es aus es mag euch überraschen
aber hätten bei den präsidentschafts
wahl nur die französischen
überseegebiete afrikas das sagen gehabt
wäre marine le pen vom rechtsgerichteten
russell blumen national die klare
siegerin gewesen was unternimmt also die
französische regierung und die dinge für
die menschen dort zu ändern nun im
grunde genommen nichts außer dem alten
fantasielosen rezept immer mehr geld zur
verfügung zu stellen
das hat die dortige entwicklung jedoch
nicht gefördert sondern die insel wie
auch die anderen gebiete in eine enorme
abhängigkeit zu paris gebracht die
fehlgeleitete subventions und
sozialpolitik ohne anreize zur
eigeninitiative hat die esel quasi zu
einer renten ökonomie innerhalb
frankreichs gemacht denn ohne permanente
alimentierung aus frankreich während
viele dieser gebiete nicht einmal in der
lage ihre grundbedürfnisse zu
befriedigen und dass dies zumindest kurz
und wohl auch mittelfristig so bleibt
garantiert die brilliante anreizstruktur
der französischen ordnungs und
finanzpolitik denn wenn du dich
einerseits mit all der schwerfällige
bürokratie und den endlosen vorschriften
aus frankreich herumschlagen muss die es
schwierig machen wettbewerbsfähige
unternehmen zu gründen und andererseits
paris dich mit geld überschüttet um alle
möglichen sozialleistungen zu
finanzieren was machst du dann wohnt er
nun alles ist eben eine frage der
anreise man versucht möglichst leicht an
möglichst viel geld zu kommen und das
heißt in diesem fall wird zum rhein t
des staates und so ist ausmaß das
geworden was es heute ist aber schauen
wir uns doch noch ein weiteres
spannendes beispiel an
[Musik]
das karibische frankreich
von mayotte aus und runden wir nur den
halben globus um wieder in frankreich zu
landen genauer gesagt auf den
karibikinseln guadeloupe macht die nikon
bartholemy und so machte von all diesen
sind die koreaner oder die matinee
anders vielleicht am wenigsten zufrieden
mit dem status quo denn ein großer teil
ihrer bevölkerung fühlt sich von paris
diskriminiert ein beispiel gefällig nun
da wäre zum beispiel der fall eines
pestizids skandals der vor ein paar
jahren in guadeloupe und martinique für
aufsehen sorgte
lotte cohn ist ein insektizid das häufig
in bananenplantagen eingesetzt wurde das
problem dabei war nur das ist nicht nur
unliebsame vergiftete sondern auch
kriegs- und missbildungen an menschen
verursachte was in diesem fall aber
besonders auffällt frankreich hat seine
verwendung in goa der luchs zugelassen
obwohl die dhs 1979 also zwei jahre
davor bereits als potenziell
krebserregend eingestuft hatte einige
zeit später kam dann auch noch heraus
dass eine parlamentarische untersuchung
auf der nachbarinsel martinique ergeben
hatte dass frankreich seit 1969 von der
schädlichkeit des insektizids wusste und
trotzdem dessen gebrauch nicht
verhinderte und so etwas trägt natürlich
wenig dazu bei ein gefühl der
zugehörigkeit zur französischen nation
zu schaffen die meisten menschen in
diesen ordnung haben eher das gefühl
dass ihr leben für die pariser
bürokraten wenig zählt
auch die erinnerungen an die zeit der
sklaverei belasten das verhältnis noch
immer besonders dass die sklavenhalter
1848 bei der abschaffung der sklaverei
zu ihren verlust entschädigt wurden
sitzt tief im kollektiven gedächtnis
kurzum wir könnten noch viele weitere
beispiele für die schlechte laune und
vergiftete atmosphäre anführen die in
übersee frankreich herrscht in den
meisten der französischen überseegebiete
gibt es nicht nur wirtschaftliche und
soziale probleme sondern auch ein
mangelndes zugehörigkeitsgefühl zur
chronifizierung welche sich in der
vergangenheit eben nicht besonders
grandios verhalten hat denn im grunde
hat man seinen firmen bürgern in paris
nicht nur nie etwas zugetraut werde ihn
auch nie richtig über den weg getraut
und sie deswegen die wir immer an der
kurzen leine gehalten hätten die
überseegebiete mehr freiheit mehr macht
und autonomie gehabt hätten sie die
vorteile einer mitgliedschaft in der eu
und zugehörigkeit zu frankreich nutzen
können um sich zu finanzieren muss oder
vielleicht sogar industrie in klagen zu
entwickeln dass dies möglich ist haben
die vielen britischen überseegebiet
demonstriert von gibraltar über das wir
bereits ein eigenes video gedreht haben
über die bermudas bis hin zu hoch
[Musik]
außerdem hätten wachsende soziale
probleme wie gewalt mangelnde sicherheit
und illegale einwanderung die
französische regierung schon vor langer
zeit davon überzeugen müssen dass die
dezentralisierung in diesen fällen die
beste und vielleicht die einzig mögliche
lösung ist es ergibt nun mal wenig sind
dass diese orte die tausende und
abertausende kilometern von frankreichs
fährt liegen in praktisch allen belangen
von paris abhängig sind und es ergibt
auch wenig sinn dass die franzosen
wirtschaftliche freiheit durch
subventionen ersetzt haben aber meine
lieben visuell politik zuschauer wir
reden hier über frankreich das
vielleicht zentralistische und
interventionistische land im guten alten
europa wenn uns diese geschichte also
etwas lehren kann dann dass wir diese
mentalität stets im auge behalten müssen
wenn es um die pariser vorstellungen
bezüglich der gestaltung und politik der
europäischen union selbst geht aber
jetzt seid ihr erst mal an der reihe was
meint ihr was sollte frankreich mit
diesen gebieten anstellen ist ein
weiterer verbleib bei frankreich
überhaupt sinnvoll oder sollten einige
der überseegebiete er die unabhängigkeit
anstreben wie könnte frankreich das
britische modell adaptieren welche
reformen während hierzu notwendig wie
immer sind wir auf eure
diskussionsbeiträge schon sehr gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt es nur
den like das neue falcon und vergesst
nicht das womit glücklich um keines
unserer videos nicht verpassen natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
spende von euch mit der uns hält dieses
projekt weiterzuführen den paper link
dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung oder
die im video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]